golde turn alright let's talk about the  fence jump how long were you gone for  and where did you go in that darkness I  was going for quite a bit I just needed  to get away I needed time and I think I  realized you know I I wanted I wanted to  just be to myself and sit in that moment  my myself and realized what's best for  me as a human being were you just  thinking what are we gonna do from here  it really was unlike anything we'd dealt  with before and so for the first you  know five minutes I thought we're  clearly gonna find him it's not that big  of a deal and then we didn't and he just  kind of broke and snapped and he was  done and I don't think I realized the  severity of it until I was trying to  walk after him and obviously you saw the  the jump of the fence and then he took  off and then what you'll see after this  is kind of the raw real emotions I don't  know what  [Music]